on se retrouve un petit peu en ce début
de quinquennat dans la situation qu'on a
vécu pour les violences faites aux
femmes dans le précédent quinquennat on
a du mal à ce que la mesure soit prise
par nos concitoyens et je vous remercie
de contribuer à apprendre aussi la
parole au travers de ce type de rapport
pour dire attention tous nos enfants ne
sont pas heureux tous nos enfants ne
sont pas roi et certains subissent des
choses évidemment totalement
traumatrices
de chiffres évidemment que je ne cesse
de répéter mais je le redirai encore un
enfant meurt dans le cadre familial tous
les cinq jours en France et la civisme
nous dit que 160000 enfants sont
victimes chaque année au moins
d'infractions sexuelles
ce qui est certain c'est qu'on se rend
compte à la lecture d'un certain nombre
de dossiers et de d'affaires judiciaires
que nous n'arrivons pas à stopper la
chaîne de reproduction des violences
nous n'arriverons pas à
casser la chaîne de reproduction des
inégalités sociales mais pas non plus
celle des violences qu'elles soient
intrafamiliales et qu'elle soit
sexuelles on le constate très souvent
les criminels d'aujourd'hui ont été les
victimes d'hier et ça ne peut que nous
interroger effectivement de manière très
forte vous le dites dans votre rapport
et c'est une de mes difficultés sur
lequel je vais essayer de travailler un
manque de données statistiques
extrêmement fort
voilà on a un constat partagé par
différentes auditions par des
prospections enfin mais on manque quand
même de donner pour des raisons à la
fois liées aux statistiques justice mais
aussi évidemment à de nombreuses
infractions qui ne sont pas révélées ou
qui n'arrivent pas jusqu'à la justice
et puis derrière évidemment l'absence de
donner juste il n'est pas toujours
facile d'avoir une stratégie claire et
partagée puisque il nous faut quand même
des données pour pouvoir travailler